i just don't know about q anon you do
know
i don't know no i don't know you know if
you go out and you want to buy groceries
you need
a picture on a card you need id
he wants to host next year's g7 summit
at his own doral golf club
gotta take care of the floors you know
the floors of the forest it's very
important
frederick douglass is an example of
somebody who's done an amazing job and
is being recognized more and more i
noticed
ivanka trump the president's daughter is
sitting in
for the secretary of state
remember that incredible night with the
maps
and the republicans are red and that map
was so red from
suchin kendo kerr
trump tweeting the new york times they
are
a true enemy of the people i think we
have enough of an interview here hope
okay that's enough let's go this russian
bounty story we have multiple sources
saying
that trump knew all along i was there
for a tiny little short period of time
it was much more for an inspection there
was no problem during the day and said
quote
crazy joe biden he doesn't know me but
he would go down
fast and hard crying all the way they'll
go out and they'll vote and they're
gonna have to go and check their vote by
going to the poll and voting that way
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
as opposed to once the state department
is emphasizing to world leaders
that they should stay at donald trump's
hotels and they say the noise causes
cancer you tell me that one okay
trump ordered robert mueller the special
prosecutor
be fired the factory policy is wear a
mask at all times
and trump puts on goggles but no mask
and we're building a wall
in colorado we're building a beautiful
wall
trump floated the idea of swapping
puerto rico for greenland the ramp that
i descended after my west point
commencement speech was very long and
steep
had no handrail and most importantly was
very slippery
our army manned the air it ran
the ramparts it took over the airports
it did everything it had to do
wherever trump goes he tries to make
himself seem dominant over whoever he's
shaking hands with trump's
strong looking situation room photo was
a staged
photograph likely taken hours after the
event
lock them up you should lock them up
lock up the bugs lock up hillary i too
have a nuclear button
but it is a much bigger and more
powerful one than his
the narcissist and chief donald trump
wanted his signature
printed on all of the checks
he's not reading a presidential daily
briefing
that has been dumbed down to one page
mostly pictures graphs and maps get that
son of a [ __ ] off the field
right now out he's fired
he's fired so in florida
i encourage all to request a ballot and
vote by mail the wind direction
shifted and it sort of split his hair
sort of back to front
trump was laughed at by the entire room
of world leaders at the united nations
one of the wettest we've ever seen
from the standpoint of water then they
did dumps
they call them dumps big massive dumps
levar ball
is unaccepting of what i did for his son
i should have left them
in jail these aren't people
these are animals the same vaccine could
not work you take
a solid flu vaccine you don't think that
would have an impact or much of an
impact on corona
no cummings district is a disgusting rat
and rodent infested mess
compared to other presidents trump has
golfed more
than any modern president cnn should be
ashamed of itself
having you working for them you are a
rude
terrible person trump showed up and
started throwing
paper towels to people like he was
shooting free throws
in basketball donald trump's decision to
do the corona caravan drive
around walter reed well it's not the
hardest test no but it
has a picture and it says and it's an
elephant no no you see
that's all misrepresentation well the
white house had put together a statement
praising mccain and his life and his
heroism trump said no no statement
i'll post a tweet instead this is the
guy
who stared directly at a solar eclipse
i wanted to always play it down i still
like playing it down
trump shared a video of a supporter of
his yelling white power
toilet paper donald trump revealed
highly classified intelligence
information
to none other than sergey kislyak the
russian ambassador you don't know until
you test it but i think i i really
believe i'd run in there even if i
didn't have a weapon
donald trump has blamed canada for
burning down the white house in 1812.
donald trump has become the third
president in the history of the united
states to be
[Music]
impeached
i guess we'll have to compare iq tests
and i can tell you who is going to win
you can test too much you do know that
who says that oh just read the manuals
read the books
read the books read the books books
trump
referred to seemingly haiti african
mostly non-white countries as [ __ ]
countries
trump also tweeting i won this election
by a lot president putin uh he just said
it's not russia
i will say this i don't see any reason
why it would be he invites a college
sports team to the white house after a
big win
and he serves them fast food option
cobb fefe this was the largest audience
to ever witness an inauguration
period alternative facts there are
pictures now
which appear to show boxes and boxes
of sudafed and upper he's going to
eliminate
overtime for hundreds of thousands of
postal workers
which could delay mail services and of
course prevent the
delivery of the ballot i am proud to
shut down the government
for border security because the people
of this country
don't want criminals and people that
have lots of problems
in fact i'll get that little piece of
dandruff for
them it'll be we have to make him
perfect he is perfect
i think that would qualify as not smart
but genius
and a very stable genius at that but
it gives me it gives me power trump
paid a total of 750
in federal income taxes the year that he
won the presidency
god bless the palestinians and god bless
the united states thank you very much he
shoves the president of montenegro
philip vujanovic out of the way and then
we fell in love
okay no really he wrote me beautiful
letters
they're trying to take you out with
[ __ ] okay
president donald trump has been
impeached again
making him the only president in history
to be
impeached two times we appreciate it
very much tim apple
trump called troops who died losers
and suckers i hope they now go and take
a look at the oranges
or the oranges of the
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation trump
uh had protesters tear gassed
and dispersed with horses for donald
trump to walk
to saint john's church and be
photographed
holding up a bible millions and millions
of people voted for us tonight
and a very sad group of people
is trying to disenfranchise that group
of people
i got it i got it why don't we nuke them
trump said we drop a bomb
inside the eye of the hurricane and
disrupt it so what are we going to do
here folks i only need 11 000 votes
fellas i need 11 000 votes give me a
break
twitter has banned donald trump
permanently from its platform michael
cohen alleges the hush money payments
for which he was convicted
for which he pled guilty were
specifically directed specifically
requested of him by donald trump himself
donald trump fired fbi director james
comey north korea best not
make any more threats to the united
states
they will be met with fire and fury
days before the july phone call between
donald trump and the ukrainian president
donald trump
ordered military aid be withheld
from ukraine with a black circle
potentially a sharpie
used to draw in a section of the florida
panhandle
and pieces of alabama give me a white
supremacy
stand back and stand by the mueller
report
there is an incredible amount of
evidence of obstruction
extraordinarily damaging to donald trump
and to the people around
him so interesting to see quote
progressive democrat congresswoman who
originally
came from countries whose governments
are a complete and total catastrophe the
worst
why don't they go back and help fix the
totally broken and crime infested places
from which they came president donald
trump has announced that he has tested
positive for coronavirus donald trump
removed his mask and what i guess was
supposed to be framed as some kind of
act of
bad people in that courage but you also
had people
that were very fine people on both sides
the trump administration
is also scaling up the number of
children that are going to be held
in these internment style camps right
and then i see the disinfectant
where it knocks it out in a minute one
minute
and is there a way we can do something
like that
by injection and we're going to the
capitol
[Music]
we love you you're very special